I know that many of you meet miracles
happen to get to this day you show them
between challenging classes and Greek
life
you worked hard studying late to the
night you have come to this moment of
incredible achievement receiving your
degree I mean then again Jeanne and I
have only been here an hour and we're
also getting one it's a great day
because today marks the end of one ERA
of your life and the beginning of
something new the stories you are about
to live are the ones you will be telling
your children and grandchildren and
therapists but seriously I know that
graduation speakers are supposed to
inspire and offer good advice but I'm
going to be honest the world is full of
bastards you won't always get everything
you want life is like the Star Wars
movies some of it is great some of it
sucks but you have no choice but to sit
through all of it the moments that
really matter are the moments when life
tells you know the days that challenge
you to your very core so don't lose hope
no matter how dark it gets just please
be honest with yourself live your dreams
not the dreams of others go out and do
what your teachers and parents thought
could not be done be excellent
be nice be impatient be persistent get
woke put down your phone
and seriously don't trip someone will
post it on YouTube
you all have some work to do it's game
time the world better get ready because
here y'all come go make it happen go
make it happen I believe in you I can't
wait to see how it turns out I wish you
all a true Hollywood style happy ending
congratulations congratulations
congratulations congratulations
congratulations congratulations class of
2016
you